[Music]
me
[Music]
nazi frags juicy
poor kids are just as bright and just as
talon's white kid president trump and
the democrats around the demagogues
around the world but i tell him if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or trump then you ain't
black we choose truth over facts
i want to be clear
i'm not going nuts
[Music]
[Music]
louder with crowder ranger panties.com
[Music]
channel
[Music]
i just made 200
how people pay for that people pay for
sounds oh whatever
crinkling a ruffles bag eating a whopper
i found out about this the internet is a
dangerous dark and scary place
uh glad to be with you we have uh we
have a lot to get to here today
uh we say that every day but we really
do it's just like it's like drinking
from a fire hose people say oh it's an
off election year well you know it's not
an off earth year
so there's still stuff to talk about and
terrible people let me lead this right
away uh there will be nazi comparisons
today now it's not like gerald yesterday
for mug club members who were he was
just throwing out seven different kinds
of nazi comparisons to win an argument
nope
it's uh there's this there's an
appropriate what are you gonna say he
just said hitler just throw it in every
once in a while and yeah oh crap there's
an appropriate time to make it there's
an appropriate time to draw comparisons
and
if we act as though there never is well
then what's the point of history right
we have to learn from history and a big
part of that comes from othering people
a big part of that comes from
eliminating voices of descent so we're
not making any comparisons today as it
relates to
gassing the jews which of course
everyone here condemns horrible just we
always have to say that just to make
sure
mel gives him a voicemail bad
um
well
but trusting the science is something
we'll talk about how we come to this
point how we come to the point what
where we see what's going on in canada
in australia here in the united states
how did we get here and it all started
with trusting the science and the danger
of the science being synonymous with uh
the government science and uh we're
gonna follow follow that trail down to
where we are today it's pretty scary and
it does mirror almost to the letter what
happened in nazi germany uh in the way
that uh they use the science and they
use communicable diseases to try and
other citizens
not saying that you're jews who are
going to be rounded up to zyklon b
showers i'm just saying that this is how
the march happens and i don't think it's
an inappropriate comparison when we're
dealing with canada and australia at
this point oh yeah forced quarantine
camps
what could go wrong there i mean that
would have been an alex jones conspiracy
that uh would have gotten him in trouble
maybe two months ago i've seen the fema
camps like oh come on crazy
and then they're just watching sky news
like yeah the fema camps
well [ __ ] yeah well shoot
so my question to you before we move on
and this is an important question today
really why do you think
that our leaders and by our leaders i
mean um
leaders in some nebulous sense
uh
cares so much about ukrainian democracy
and not about canadian democracy
let me rephrase it because ukrainian
canadians sound the same different
places different continents why do you
think they're making such a big deal
about ukrainian democracy of course
there's a good reason right to go to war
and not about canadian democracy
i think it's an important uh an
important distinction to make but if
this show is uh not on youtube if you
don't see us on youtube if ever you go
hey where's the show we are here monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern and of
course it's available on rumble and on
mug club a full hour [ __ ] the best place
to watch is mug club loudoun.com club
but the free show for those of you who
are still on the fence you can watch it
at rumble nothing would make me happier
than to see you switch over from youtube
to rumble but uh here we are before we
move on gerald how are you i am doing
well the nazi comparisons i used by the
way were very fitting and i won the
argument yeah just saying well you were
getting fitted for a nice hugo boss ss
unit well they were classy uniforms
nobody argues that nobody has a problem
with it how are you nobody ever said
they weren't stylish no even the allies
showed up they were like wow those are
impressive i mean i hate to can you do
this so i can shoot you and keep the
coat yeah exactly i don't so much want
to collect the lugers uh i want to
collect the pea coats gosh hogan's
heroes largely based on the likability
of the nazi unified also the inspiration
for every harley-davidson motorcycle
half-nazi helmet that came afterward
that's true when you see people down
it's like oh well you put up you
literally put the horn on it
either you're that little guy from
labyrinth or
you're half you're half ss yes when
you're riding down the uh the freeway
i'm okay i drank a little bit of wine
last night because it was my mother's
birthday and i'm in a very like half a
glass it always gives me a headache
anyone else does that happen to you guys
like i have beer i'm fine but wine for
some reason it doesn't uh i don't do
well with it well i said every time i
drank i got a headache well yeah
it tastes like i don't have a little bit
of wine i had a fifth that might come in
fact i don't know how christ did it but
you know what he's perfect not me also
uh here is uh you know you'll love him
and i will be on tour with him you can
go live crowder.com
tour may 14th tulsa oklahoma that's a
big venue tickets are selling quickly
dave landau how are you sir ahoy how
about you i'm fine except joe lewis hey
come on go back to your back over there
this is the problem with when you give
him treats out there now he's going over
to dave
i don't want to pet nobody to tell him
this is good but i want to pet him
because i love him he joe lewis is
working
he's working everybody in the room
because of the storm and so this morning
i wake up at like three which is an hour
earlier than i usually get up and i just
hear
he's ramming his head into the door you
can see there's a little bit of blood on
the top of his head what really is yeah
just from ramming the door oh wow to try
and get in because of the storm yeah and
but this thing will he's not even afraid
of the storm he was just working the
room
dogs they're not fans joe lewis i have
to move on and talk about cardi b and
not come on buddy but he doesn't want
that nobody wants that
lewis
place come on buddy good dog
one of these days he's just going to
knock over the camera and be like yeah
how do you like that place all right
there we go he's just going to be
sitting in steven's seat
with the earphones
screw you just roar
just slurping from his bowl
did i do it right nope
[Laughter]
join bowl club um it's just decapitated
people we have to do bowl club for
people with dogs why didn't we just
absolutely perfect we just made a
million dollar idea i don't know if you
know this but it has been said in a new
focus group by nielsen that 40 percent
of pets watch television if you'll
notice that's why we have more like
bones sometimes we'll have a piece piece
of yarn you know what i mean
no i don't my dog does but it's mostly
very violent movies about dogs yes ah
yeah strange i don't know why your dog
loves the ending to marley and me it's
weird it almost seems he's he like he
doesn't clap cause he can't but he puts
his balls right yeah exactly
[Laughter]
just like that golden retriever dead uh
by the way i meant to talk about that i
think your dog might be possessed that's
possible yeah if he tells you to kill
anybody don't listen he does fly yeah
well
[Laughter]
davey berkowitz he was so good with the
dog all right
here's something else that we have to
talk i have not watched this i was
instructed not to watch this before the
program so uh because we're going to
talk about something they're a little
bit heavy you know nazi stuff but hey
you know what we'll make it fun
this beautiful and uh brave
person
on ins this is how i was told to
describe it on instagram explained why
women remember how at one point women
needed their own spaces
this thing women-only spaces
and that was the thing we said okay that
makes sense like curves
you know
weight watchers plus james corden right
um
well now women don't need their own
spaces watch this uh uh
z explain it i think you have to get
really specific about why you want the
space and what the space is for because
just like women's spaces is a nebulous
concept like what is the purpose of this
space for women the space to get away
from space that's for women
automatically includes trans women and
it's nobody's job to police everyone
else's identities you are safer with
trans women than without but if you're
creating a collective space for people
who experience misogyny that's not just
women it's women it's non-binary people
it's trans men but then if you
specifically want a space without men a
space for non-men that would include
women and non-binary people in a myriad
of other genders and if it's for a
bathroom like we all show the same
bucket go in the stall do your business
leave so the population is going to
change based off the purpose of that
space so that's for the safety of this
case that's dependent on the kind of
people not their individual identities
any person is capable of causing harm so
if this is a private space like what's
your vetting system to allow his dad
doesn't invite him on vacation most of
them aren't safe anyway and that begets
the bigger conversation of how do we
teach people not to harm each other does
it get the oh does does harm count you
wearing a skin suit yes
i don't know what she said
yes and furthermore
i don't care i don't know that she i
don't know what she is well stephen
yeah we all [ __ ] in the same bucket do
we cause i don't want to be part of it
yeah i don't i think that's just
something that you folks do where do you
live and it's weird it's nobody's job to
police identities it's actually the
police's job to make sure that men don't
go into women's restrooms you know why
that's literally the police officer's
jobs we don't have a lot of women
hanging out in men's restrooms looking
to take advantage of men doesn't really
happen that's why it's a problem yeah to
you well i mean it's one of those things
like you know that okay that person
obviously looks
is this person non-bi do we know is this
person none but we're going to play
newest gender pronouns on mug club
because we can't discuss it on youtube i
don't know how this person identifies i
don't know but if this person identifies
as anyone other than a man with the
perfect epilated laser-lined beard
put some effort into it my point is if
you're going to claim to be non-binary
if you're going to claim to be a woman
look you want me to use the pronouns
fine just come close to passing the
eyeball test sell me on it it is man i
want to know you're kidding you just
look like you're in like the band's
sponge yes i don't know how to what are
you right you look like andrew w.k went
on a diet and got a facial peel yeah i
get that you're trans but
are you transitioning yeah are you
always in the transition then are you
just a trans-atlantic freak like does it
start
where you're like like why do you stop
yeah if you dig well you know i mean it
would be like if we looked at the fossil
records and just well then there's just
uh stops here shallow epicus i don't
know but aren't there humans no that's
not a thing not that we're aware of no
no men can get pregnant yeah they can't
though yeah men can get pregnant men can
have periods right yeah it's just like a
halloween mask with the blood pump i'm
saying oh yeah it's the exact same i now
experience all the splendor that is
woman
a myriad of other genders by the way
that was my favorite comment i'm like oh
gosh but here's the thing i would be
lying if i didn't say that i
i i don't find satisfaction some you
know masculine feminist in a female only
space and
that
thing walks in
it's like
you want to be the world's most powerful
genie everything that comes with it
well everything you say is a riddle yeah
that's the problem i don't understand
what you mean something
so you want men in there because it's a
safe space there's a box and then we all
poop in a bucket i was going to say i
noticed you're missing a bucket we use
the toilet yeah why would you have a
bucket dude we use the toilet
that's not going to work for me
let's make sure we get the bucket also
let's all by the way let's all
share okay all right joe lewis
well in fairness we did make him watch
that that fellas well the young lady i i
honestly don't know which way do we know
i don't that person i'm pretty sure it
is a man transitioning into being a
woman uh sure okay
okay it's a silver chair yes
all right my name is try not to get us
banned
i'm trying to name terrible 90s bands
because it's painted nails long hair
yeah and and stubble was painted nine
inch nails yeah does every video ooh
does anybody know what that means
you do
i found uh was the length of the nails
that crucified jesus smell it says they
she
that's a zeiss they she what's the day
for oh my god
you said that again she hurts yeah i
thought you have to pick they're not
even picking their own language they
it's not a thing no they is not a thing
grammatically it just it it's like nails
on it's like nails that are chalkboard
it's like nails on your your mat strike
beard
i don't know that's what he jamie looked
like before the
that's how jamie do who cares do what
you want that's that's that's a shitty
alone
like it's obviously interesting it's
obviously an effort to keep the five
o'clock shadow right has it set to the
george clooney level and trims the beard
lines like it looks to me like i'm a
good looking woman
i just hope that on planes they're like
is there a transgender bathroom and
they're like we have a bucket yes
because apparently we all use the same
one it's been used by brian stelter good
luck yes this person is the only person
who specifically books the last row
because
z can be nearest to the bucket yes i'd
like to be
near the poop yes
i like to have a good view of the bucket
that everyone i like to eat a confusing
meal and then poop in the box yes
exactly
if i could be in first class to get the
free meal and cocktail but they don't
let me bring the bucket up there so i'll
call the aclu we just need not to harm
each other stephen that's the easiest
part yeah well what about everyone else
being harmed by sharing fecal matter in
a bucket well that's your a woman wants
to go into a woman's only space and now
she has to get a fecal transplant
have you ever been in a men's restroom
do you know what that smells like you
don't want none of that i just i know
why
women's west restrooms are wonderful
have you been in them they smell nice
they're so much better yeah there's
couches when you walk in good lighting
ears yeah i'm in them all the time now
they go in and they've got that guy's
nose hairs in a bucket
you go into a men's room and it's like
joe biden waiting to sniff your hair
like something changed at this
applebee's restroom no it's the poop
filled bucket with
oh with the nail trimmings that's what
it is it smells better than applebee's
and we're all the same
entirely equal wonderful
i just i just okay i wouldn't say equal
i would say better than that yeah here's
yes better than greater than greater
than because it's like your equal plus a
beard and that's the that's the that's
my new gender is greater than just to
piss everybody off for crying out loud
we used to have the bearded lady because
it was a freak
yet the show she used to be
it used to be it used to be back in the
day now it's just the now it's just the
average it's just your run-of-the-mill
lady pooping in a bucket they don't have
freak shows anymore though at the circus
no they can't have brave shows right yes
because the world has become a freak
bravery it's just that person on a
unicycle
[Music]
and just
wow can we throw peanuts at it
here's the brave man with just a torso
lighting a cigarette yes amazing
where's his bucket the bucket is phil
are those peanut shells no that's poop
that's just well you know what they like
their peanuts
oh gosh all right well you know what
this is the world your children have to
be raised when people say why do you
talk about the issues you know i don't
think there's any more important issue
in our time than the idea that men and
women exist okay and you know what it it
actually
it really does it extends its gender
neutral tentacles into everything
because we see this in canada where you
don't use the right pronouns oh well
guess what you can be arrested you're a
comedian who makes the wrong joke in
canada you can be arrested we see that
happening in australia and then of
course they try to cancel through other
ways here in the united states in uh you
know exerting pressure right leveraging
on private corporations who really are
one the same with the government who act
as the jackpoo thugs of the government
and so if we get to the point where men
and women cease to exist and it's hate
speech for you to think that they do
first off you're not trusting the
science
second
it's over yeah well in your other i mean
the world well that's true but you're
othered for saying that men should not
go into women's restrooms because you're
trying to keep a place safe for women at
a vulnerable moment where they could be
all alone in a room with something they
don't know but it doesn't the guy it
doesn't matter because there always has
to be this idea of conflict with people
yeah so let's say we give everybody what
the give everybody what they want right
right yeah then it's just a new thing
well human nature dave we'll we'll just
we'll be perfect then we won't hurt one
another no it'll be a perfect utopia of
whatever that [ __ ] was
i just saw this that you know the guy
who split his tongue to become like a
lizard yeah hands what yeah yeah he's
becoming like a lizard person i don't
know disappointed he did that who killed
his neighbors and he's in prison i'm not
even kidding he could have never seen
that coming yeah who thought he was so
nauseous he had a lizard sound tattooed
your eyes sketch artists
let me see
forked tongue
scales on skin oval face got it right
lives over there in the house that plays
death metal until four right yeah it's
weird the one that smells like corpses i
thought he wasn't a i thought he was an
aguar cover band here's the thing we
think it's absurd at least that tongue
is functional
true still works all right
so speaking of all of this and of the
totalitarianism that is sweeping the
world it's a pandemic dave
um yesterday prime minister blackface
himself trudeau uh nine times the black
face just to be clear not once nine
times announced that canada will be
sanctioning russia oh good to stand
against and keep in mind this is the
same canada you're thinking about i know
some of you think is there another
candidate no it's the same canada same
prime minister standing against russia
to stand against authoritarianism canada
and our allies will defend democracy
shut up we are taking these actions
today
to stand against why are there two
signers
the people of ukraine
like all people must be free to
determine their own future we will
continue working with our international
partners to safeguard ukraine's
territorial integrity and prevent
further russian aggression hold on a
second silver lining i see an
opportunity you know what ukraine should
make their next export huh uh
translators yeah signers uh oh yeah
that's is there is there a law is there
a law against having normal slash
healthy signers in north america
is there a meeting behind our back that
i didn't know about well sometimes i
mean her hands are in shape yeah
crack a lobster there were some very
weird ones for new york she had shan
hands
so canada they want to oh did we just
turn up the volume here a little bit
okay canada they want to stand against
authoritarianism in uh
russia ukraine well that sounds noble
enough right if you're anti-authoritar
okay that's good we should be on the
same side but we've talked about canada
quite a bit and just in canada a convoy
organizer we didn't cover this yesterday
tamara lick was arrested
uh denied bail oh my gosh for organizing
the convoy and uh biden also spoke about
so we're seeing this in canada and then
united states spoke about the sacrifice
that would be required to defend freedom
and you first he starts that phrase like
oh he's you know he's turning he's
turning baby face no to defend freedom
in ukraine as i said last week
defending freedom will have cost
for us as well and here at home
we need to be honest about that
but as we will do but as we do this
i'm going to take robust action to make
sure the pain of our sanctions is
targeted at a russian economy not ours
so if you take any robust action it
results in pain like any role
he's a walking walking robux and
commercial what joe biden basically just
said now when we fire missiles i'm gonna
make sure they don't hit us
there is no one
won't hurt i'm like what the oh my gosh
now one clip exists where he doesn't
stutter i know
he can't get out of center just read
we're gonna take
robocop actions
no more nuke on the streets oh oh jeez
so these are by the way and i'm just
sorry i'm looking through this i'm a
little disorganized today train's coming
again i can't see i i'm trying to say
this similar to his uh remarks on canada
where biden said nothing absolutely not
that's true people being arrested people
being trampled by uh by arabian horses
yeah lives ruined for parking a truck
yeah that is basically what we're
talking about that's cool so this is the
question these people who are obviously
internationally focused right the term
globalist is almost overused where
people try and say oh that
you mean that because you're an
anti-semite that's what you really mean
no no
when i'm saying trudeau and i'm saying
biden these people are globalists but
these people definitely
their primary focus seems to be an
international interest
why is it that they only care about
democracy and freedom abroad
do you think that mate let me ask you
this let's say that if russia didn't go
in physically but russia just
went to ukraine took over their
government said you now need passports
to travel
we're now going to shut down protests
yeah here in the ukraine if we're not
going to shut down voices of dissent
against russia no actual physical
violence they say we're going to have
forced quaran team camps would these
leaders go in and try to ensure that
democracy could thrive in the ukraine
why is it they only care about it over
there yeah exactly i mean we've got a
neighbor to our north dealing with this
right now why isn't it time to stand in
solidarity with our brothers and sisters
in canada they're so close to the border
anyway it's not like we would have to
travel far right right let's just do it
yeah come on well because be a part of
standing up for the agenda i wouldn't be
opposed to just taking over canada i
wouldn't either i don't think canada
would be opposed to you taking over
canada no i don't think so like hey guys
remember when you burned down the white
house yeah that was a real jerk move but
we're taking you over revenge is a dish
beth served two centuries late yes i'll
be honest i didn't know that happened
until i was
it technically wasn't a country no it
was technically still a colony i believe
but they brag about it they really like
they really consider that their big win
that they burst like the real white
house or the richmond one not the real
one it was a real white house
yeah they showed up and we're just like
hey what are you guys doing like oh
nothing so we went out for dinner
because we thought it was safe with the
canadians so we came back we're like
what the f
come on come on like oh well we pulled
one over on you you're like all right
god save the queen
all right well we'll allow you to exist
for a little while longer because we're
benevolent
so basically they just blew up the golf
course like hattieshack yes pretty
effective
rodney's putting on a big show just
leave for an hour i'm all right
don't have to worry about me
okay so they're coming back luckily we
did get some uh expert opinions though
on uh the ukraine crisis
and it's a cr it's a crisis dave
well yeah pandemic from none other than
cardi b oh thank god she wrote uh wish
these world leaders stop tripping about
power and really think about who's
really getting affected in parentheses
citizens don't you love that everything
else is a grammatical holocaust right
and then but she's like i gotta use a
parenthesis on that [ __ ]
also i i call it ellipses you call that
dot dot dot that is disgusting i call it
half circle left half circle right but i
despise conjunctions smiley face friday
face getting affected citizens besides
the whole world is in a crisis war
sanctions invasion should be the last
thing these leaders should worry about
okay
um
you think about knocking somebody out
and stealing his wallet while you were a
stripper
i did that every now for real ever think
about pushing some man named chan in the
subway on the subway train
jiva have an interview with the
president and talk about your yeast
infection i did i did
it's me i did bought him some votes
that's right i voted nine times don't
eat chicken and then do stuff with that
you buy you you vote for button i buy
y'all cars
[Laughter]
so she did clarify though that she
wasn't into taking sides when she got
backlash oh it's not hacked it's really
me i actually want to say a lot of
things but i'm just going to mind my
business because
sometimes i feel like i have such a big
platform that if i say if i don't say
the right things i might get killed but
i'm really not on nato's side i'm really
not in russian side
i'm actually in the citizen side because
at the end of the day the world is
having a crisis right now there's
inflation not only in america but
everywhere in the world
it's really hard to get um
the economy back up
there is so much shipments and
embarkments backed up
china is not really messing with us so a
lot of things are behind a lot of goods
are behind and this [ __ ] has made it
away a lot of goods are behind i'm just
really annoyed by this and i really wish
that all world leaders right china's not
messing with us though because she
doesn't know where wuhan is
whatever
yes whatever
it's always great when a woman says a
lady says you know i should mind my
business but then stop
well it's what you should say next is
nothing yeah well if you knew what you
were talking about you know it helped
right yeah it's why i didn't tweet
anything about it
i don't like drama but
did you hear about this yeah exactly i
don't want to spread a rumor but yeah
what i care about is the citizens well
then on what side yes which city exactly
well uh all of them that's a good point
yeah good we are the world but what
about the portion of the world that
wants to kill everyone else in the world
i i'll buy your cars yeah you know when
uh you care about citizens you have to
stop the people trying to kill the
citizens and that usually requires
sports well tomato
tomato but don't think about it i have
black pupils like that banned in the 90s
not afi was it alo i think it was a-l-o
a-l-o
well at least she said inflation's bad
you know right there no i have no idea
okay she doesn't know what inflation is
no well well that's how she you know
before she goes after her show she has
to the posterior yeah
and embarkments i'm not sure what those
were it popped i don't know what an
embarrassment is either yeah now watch
it's like some like fancy financial term
and i'm like oh maybe she just bought it
yeah you have no idea may have been word
of the day i greatly await her advice on
cryptocurrency i can't wait i i take all
my advice from her on literally ever yes
yeah uh and also by the way she had some
very helpful advice surprisingly for the
russian soldiers well let me tell y'all
young to something yeah i definitely
don't know how to really wash your ass
because when you get older that's when
you know how to wash your ass you put
your whole finger inside your [ __ ]
and you pour a little brown and
everything and you wash your hands like
this almost like you're playing with
your [ __ ] but you're really not
yep
or be it from me to question or expert
advice but sometimes it's do you keep
that to yourself my issue is more or
less doing it with five inch nails yes
yes i feel like she's doing some serious
damage yeah well at this point i don't
think she could tell they're like look
that's washing cardi b it's very very
important wash us change socks in that
order plus russians aren't going to
understand like wash ass that's just old
wives tale
it's self-cleaning yes it's a whole
i have a bidet yes it's my friend and
but yes at the bath house
his name is
yes the ass cleans itself through uh
hair friction it's like uh it's like uh
it's like a steel wool on pot
[Music]
she seriously does that that she did
after the biden thing when she was
talking about don't eat like certain
foods and then go at your girl with your
fingers and you're like wow that is yeah
amazing that you just interviewed the
president remember when people were
offended uh not offended but they were a
little bit disconcerted that uh barack
obama was being interviewed by that uh
that african-american lady who uh was in
a was in a bathtub with cereal
yeah something green oh wow
anyway the point is we are way beyond
that oh yeah oh no this is horrible like
huh cardi b yeah that makes sense just
be cardi b you've made it if you want
the russians to surrender right now just
blare it from the speakers you're the
american dream right you're you've made
it to the top for no reason that's what
they're doing
it's their mental warfare like the nazis
when they're going to poland it's like
all is lost you feel surrender the
russians are just going and they're
playing over their tanks gotta clean
your [ __ ] with your nails and i'm
gonna come in and show you how to clean
[ __ ] please no we give up
no more i care about all the citizens
[ __ ] not just on one side yes
exactly i mean i just think the citizens
in parentheses people that's right
because if we don't all properly clean
[ __ ] then we're gonna have problems
using the same bucket
i know that guy girl
what we've got to say
i gotta i've got a breaking news update
oh really good for carter remember how
we were trying to get banned on tick
tock did we no
but all right the video the video was
taken down with the community guideline
violation saying that we were engaging
in harassment and bullying of who which
would be like what xi jinping pink this
thing has a microphone
now have they are they going to put it
back up do we know i don't know that yet
but they haven't taken us down so
we're gonna have to try again we're
gonna have some gigi peng is admitting
he has a micro penis yeah upset by that
that's true okay all right let's try
this for tick tock uh hashtag trash tick
tock i don't know if we can have this up
this is this is breaking uh xi jinping
hasn't trimmed his nails thus doesn't
properly clean his [ __ ]
xi jinping you have a disgusting
smelly unclean
sphincter
that's why your nickname is winnie
smells like poo yes
[Laughter]
oh bother obama
[Music]
i don't know is there anything else that
we can say to get me banned from tick
tock i mean we've tried just about
everything i don't know you know what
we'll take your chat here on mug club
afterwards what would be go i mean we
just i mean we took a i mean we took a
steaming dump in the bucket that is a
communist chinese party certainly and uh
i mean i left a fake mustache in there
yeah they're just fighting back going no
we don't care yeah they're just
pretending they don't they're just
pretending they don't know they're
furious
[ __ ] yeah
that was the uh the rest of the quote
yeah imagine the guy that has to show
him
[Laughter]
he's immediately signing his own death
warrant oh yeah we've already had four
people killed
i i have news from lara with crowder
bring it here i i don't want
i said bring here now now and read as if
it's your own words micro penis
how do i know
how to clean [ __ ]
no i didn't realize it's my nail cuticle
have poo-poo on my nail
oh man you have any idea what would
happen if cardi b tried to make it in uh
in chinese cinema you mean killed at
birth yes
yeah no no no no left alone on a
mountain to die dave
that's what we sit here and we complain
people have no idea crazy no idea how
good we are they really don't there's no
appreciation for how great this country
is hey by the way speaking of things
that were banned you know the socialism
for fig's shirt got banned of course
where youtube wouldn't even allow us to
have it off of youtube at
loudershop.com but now we have the
socialism dunce capture yeah so that's
perfect yeah we've got some another
couple of shirt ideas coming around that
might uh you know
yeah well this is also for people who
don't know unlike rage against a machine
like tom morello they don't understand
that che guevara was just like hitler
minus the charm well that's and the
effectiveness yeah they don't they yeah
exactly just because he was i mean he
was he was an absolute coward was it he
built a window to watch people yeah he
broke down a wall to watch people get
assassinated yeah get executed and he
specifically executed uh blacks
gays uh he stood before i believe the
u.n and said execute without trial of
course we'll continue to execute without
trial yeah uh and he was also a coward
who never actually fought an award
despite what motorcycle motorcycle
diaries tells you i believe he was found
if i'm not mistaken i'm going by wrote
bolivia and he was holding a fully
loaded un unfired rifle saying i'm worth
more to you alive than dead yeah there
you go there's your revolutionary hero
i just want to tell them that yeah uh
i'm not entirely sure if they i don't
know when he died the next sentence
should be no you're not bam yeah that's
why i'm wondering that's what i would
have done yeah then take his motorcycle
here's your trial the same one you gave
everybody else what were they witches
and you're trying to get rid of them
yeah i am an american that appreciates
my country i'm not leaving my couch
right cuban americans
they do not tolerate social media no
they they hate it or they've seen what
my agent is cuban you met him yeah not a
fan not a fan and uh i don't think it's
uh i don't think we're letting out of
the bag that he uh
a little light in the loafers well a
little yeah he's a little light in the
loafers but he's cuban and he hates
hates socialists
it's always so weird when you hear
something like those [ __ ] on the
left i just could kill every last one of
them they're like wait i just i i just
want to slap them they're like wow and
spank them hold on
oh good they're bringing up
he had a guy living with a there's like
a goat in front of his house you know
just in la because that's how it is now
yeah and all the neighbors are
complaining he's like you voted for this
i hope there's the whole petting zoo
here tomorrow
it's like his lawn but it's like i can't
even tell this man with a goat and a
mattress to leave right somehow that's a
crime
and dear god i hope i don't misgender
him all the way out
i just miss it when it was the mormons
who wouldn't let us marry now i have
goat [ __ ] everywhere use a bucket eats
everything doesn't even i'm married
so speaking of uh uh speaking of you
know right now we were just talking
about cardi b speaking of eras coming to
an end uh 25 seasons on the air oh my
first job the show arthur on pbs just
aired its final episode oh no
monday ending the longest running kids
animated show uh of all time and they
kind of did a fast forward so we know
how they end up because you know we were
concerned it's bizarre that they never
aged for 25 years and then the final
episode they aged 18 years
but that's how it works sure yeah uh so
arthur actually and for those of you who
want to know i know that those of you do
want to know arthur ended up as a
hipster graphic novelist
unfortunately his first foray was a
graphic novel and jeffrey epstein so
didn't have the happiest ending oh wow
yeah yeah well that happens
what a wonderful time to hang i must
have found his kid's bucket uh coroner
suspect covet just to be clear in the
final sure yeah yeah
uh francine if you remember francine she
apparently became a leslie jones
look-alike lesbian shoe salesman
oh that's weird
i thought arthur and dw were the
anteaters
well they are dave yeah no
no but yes
uh and there was no character arc
unfortunately for everyone's favorite
character the brain so oh that was oh
that was my job so sorry a lot of people
know i was the brain on arthur for
several seasons hey you wanna you wanna
have uh you wanna require years of
therapy get fired at 13 years old
unceremoniously because you've aged out
yeah like your voice changed no it
didn't like shut up get out of here
you're gone kid you're gone i don't care
what were you just your voice or did you
have to do you know what's funny is i
was the second brain and so i had to do
an impression of the first kid so i was
able to do it when i was a kid able to
do a spot on impression of the brain but
then when i got older i couldn't do that
impression anymore um they just fired
you
they just brought in a 13 year old and
hurt his feelings they didn't even call
me into a room really really what they
do in front of everybody oh
really yes oh
man your craft services are like what
are you doing
i didn't think you were still here put
the nature valley bar down put the
nature valley bar
down but a former brain for four seasons
we found a younger adorable boy
whose voice doesn't sound like he's been
changed smoking well come on i don't
think you're gonna find anyone kieran
culkin all right karen called paul that
makes sense he's beautiful
now i know i you know i when i did
arthur and i know we will be moving on
everything that mattered when i did
arthur this match guys you can smash the
like button it's a little more casual
here today because this was something i
i did and the wonderful thing is i did
do the christmas special so i still get
them royalty checks
i realized when i was a kid that i hated
leftists because i had to do the kwanzaa
rap
and so this was when i was 12. and then
i learned about kwanzaa could they have
fired you before then
how old are you 15 when did kwanza come
out yeah well you know that's the thing
was pretty new yeah it was shiny new
quantities you find out about it that
day yeah and then i had to explain it on
the show like these actually these are
three uh i was scooping i think ice
cream for arthur we can bring it up on
mug club probably uh the kwanzaa thing
from the brain what is it exactly it's
when uh kwanzaa is nothing yeah it's
when a guy named ron everett who called
himself something karenga changed his
name who also was a convicted sex
criminal who beat women with fire hoses
and would stick hot irons on their face
and pour bleach down their mouths
because he had sex slaves and then he
said something something africa uh
kwanzaa we need something that uh you
know divides americans and a bunch of
white americans decided that they would
act as though it's a real thing go to
africa say kwanzaa and they'll just be
like that's not a that's not enough
that's not a thing i was always told it
was james earl jones comes back and
forgives your child support debt yes
well
well that would be you're thinking of
the sandlot ii oh and it was
straight to vhs for a reason i gotcha
yeah there's not a big dog there's just
a big stack of bills right
sitting there blind ugh that's an
alimony check
for one of the specific kids yes
benny the jet okay
uh there's diabetes speaking of this
actually these smalls there's no you're
killing you yes sorry your diabetes is
killing you right sugarfoot
um sweating epstein there's an update on
epstein so an associate of epson now was
i don't know if you know this was just
found dead in a cell no way weird french
modeling agent jean-luc brunel was found
dead uh in uh his prison cell now he'd
been charged with raping at least one
minor but
he allegedly pimped out over a thousand
girls to jeffrey epstein which frankly
like the worst it's just a thousand
girls that just sounds exhausting yeah
it does seem like at a certain point how
can you spare the fluids but how can you
deny the ethic yeah well look there's
he didn't give up two things can be true
hey come on
if you if it first you don't succeed
rape then rape again yeah put on that
hard hat and get to work well magic
johnson slept with over a thousand women
so he's like well i've got a yes women
going forward well yeah but he was a
celebrity they were coming to him that's
true
and then they were like i have what yeah
ah and by they we mean
ladies yes
yes tons and tons of
women yes
which brings us actually to curious
coincidences
[Music]
okay so um this person brunell it said
that uh brunel hung himself with his bed
sheets
yeah in case you remember you know
epstein a little bit of similarity there
but unlike his buddy epstein um
the cell did not have cameras for people
who don't remember like well didn't
happen epstein's cell did have cameras
but they just shut off
like how many wait hold on a second
which angle did we lose all of them i
have no idea suicide watch with guards
posted outside we have a sponsorship
with ring
there was a glyph a glitch
a glitch and a guard change well there
was a guard named glyph yeah glyph
jiminy glyph he said i love jeffrey
epstein i love it when he hangs himself
let me do that again time to take a
break time to break your highlight bone
[Laughter]
so unlike his pal epstein uh there were
no cameras okay but there were
there were like six
prison patrols and he was under constant
watch and he still managed to kill
himself with the bed sheets um and he
had a bed sheets first of all which is a
bit strange right yeah a shaving kit
yeah a lot of stuff was going on yeah
and a toothbrush with a toothpick with
these already sharpened
nothing to see here yeah
[Music]
oh epstein the gift that just keeps on
killing you know just he just knew a lot
of depressed people yeah that's exactly
it they were all in the same they were
all in the same child rapist support
group yeah just a lot of sad people who
were like
uh
what is control what what is that
no no no that steve steven that's that's
my bad i don't know if we actually told
you but bill barr actually sent a new
rep in for so they're just they're kind
of jamming he's been causing quite a
ruckus
[Music]
dude chill it's just a jack rabbit
a jack rabbit
what does he want
he wants to give you one of those
delicious build bars as as a gift
he's sweet
thanks jack rabbit
[Music]
[Applause]
that was nice
yeah he likes to spread joy yeah he's
one of the good ones
a little uh a little rough in bed though
put me in a hospital bed for about three
weeks right
[Music]
by the way we wrote that not built
just to make sure i don't want to get
any angry calls i am down i am down 26.
yeah 26 pounds nice 26 pounds because i
just use and all right look no one needs
protein bars obviously like i was like
when people like i've had a protein bar
i'm gonna become you're not gonna become
jack rabbit okay that is years of work
yes still lost to the tortoise though
just can't just doesn't learn to not
take those naps
well twerking toward us definitely
changed his ways he absolutely has yeah
now we have to do a twerk and tortoise
at cardi box turtle
um go to built.com use the promo code
crowder15 to get 15 off i just use them
like dessert they're delicious this is
the birthday cake this is actually my
this is the favorite of someone in the
office it's my least favorite
uh but their new chocolate uh fudge it's
like fudge brownie with coconut and that
double it's chocolate that was really
good they just taste really good they
have real chocolate in there and you
know what you can either replace dessert
or if you're scrawny eat a couple built
bars you know put some meat on your
bones maybe maybe one day you too can be
a jackrabbit i steal them from the
office what boxes dave i don't need to
steal them they're a sponsor oh you know
it's the thrill oh i just want to make
it yeah like i'm taking some sort of
like when i was at pbs and i would i
would have my fill of those nature
valley bars at the craft stable oh and
me and the gang go into a prison and
hang a guy yeah ah and i'll poop in a
bucket
turn off cameras have a good time so
this is something uh that i do we're
going to talk about here today because
we've
you know it's a slow march to tyranny
it's a slow march into an authoritarian
regime and i i defended gina carrano
when she made this comparison on
instagram because there are stupid
people just go you're just like hitler
okay no that's silly but when gina
carano said gerald when gina carano said
uh how did it start it started by
neighbors turning on neighbors it
started not just with a regime but by
convincing neighbors to turn on each
other and to other groups of people i
thought that was a thoughtful legitimate
comparison because we had people turning
folks into the government for not
wearing a mask or now you see in canada
for not uh honoring the vaccine the mrna
injection mandate
um
but how have we gotten here i think
sometimes it's important to sort of look
at a boiling look at look at an
inflection point i should say
and
i have been spending a lot of time
thinking about this
and uh by the way you guys can comment
below before you watch this segment
where you think it started you know how
did we end up with quarantine camps
and freezing bank accounts
right and
passports you know vaccine uh passports
how do we end up here
what was the tipping point because there
were a lot of steps
and i do think there's one
um i think
the most important one
and this is where there is a comparison
that i'm going to make it's shocking
once i started doing more research as to
how it parallels this
is
telling people it started with this
trust the science
that's how it started now what do i mean
but there's more to that that phrase
people say trust the science well that
sounds good right just like pro-choice
that sounds good but yeah trust but we
all trust science why would we not trust
science the scientific process but when
you
equate trusting the science
with exclusively
trusting and being coerced into trust
the gov into trusting the government
mandated science yeah
that's when the problem starts and then
you include into that well the idea and
we'll go through all this eliminating
voices of scientific dissent no matter
how legitimate they may be then you get
to the point where you can go through
the phase of othering people and once
you've divided people once you've
created a second class of citizenry
well then you're pretty much free to do
whatever you want to them including
freezing their bank accounts and jailing
them indefinitely so this started with
uh trusting the science and the experts
let me just show you in case you've
forgotten i believe this is the
inflection point uh that led us to what
we see in canada and see in australia
and would absolutely see in the united
states if former vice president biden
had his way we just have checks and
balances we follow the science why are
adults believing people on the internet
instead of science and experts i have a
wild idea just hear me out follow the
science science is evolving what if we
all just did science this is so silly
that we had people who are anti-science
science is moving and we are following
the science of experts on the other hand
science and not trying to silence the
voice of science and experts we all need
to follow science to protect our loved
ones we need to listen to scientists and
experts science and the truth we should
be letting public health lead
you're really attacking not only dr
anthony fauci you're attacking science i
think
science because you've got to be guided
by the science and the current data
attacks on me quite frankly are attacks
on science it's it's preposterous chuck
totally preposterous
you notice he hasn't really uh crawled
out of his hole as much lately
because he was so wrong about stuff yeah
i have no idea maybe you got the uh
omicron and he's one of the point zero
zero zero zero uh zero deaths oh that'd
be so sexy i'm joking not zero deaths i
just mean statistically very little do
you think he grew a conscience finally
and was like oh what man those dogs i
just no not about the covid but about
the dogs like ah the beagles well that
was wrong sebastian bach said on twitter
that the science is 100 accurate right i
mean so i go i don't know how he grows a
conscience because i mean the
multiplication of zero is still zero
well that's true
so
um
and by the way when we say science this
is important for you to note and this is
when people always try and make this
theory about the first amendment right
and they say well private platforms can
do whatever they want the science was
what the cdc the science was what the
who and this is who youtube twitter
instagram facebook they said this is how
we are going to fact check information
and by the way guess what information
gets fact checked even information that
is questioning their fact check from
other legitimate scientists this is when
it's scary when the government says
trust the science and the only science
that becomes that can be considered
valid
is the one
and i mean the one one scientific theory
that is funded by them classical
liberals really i know we have a lot of
you watching i just wonder where you are
when you complain about campaign finance
reform you complain about special
interests in politics why all of a
sudden why all of a sudden with the left
do they not see a conflict of interest
with the government funding science
there's no problem with the government
funding some science right as long as
all other scientific voices
are that's part of the scientific
process science isn't determined by
consensus that's the thing it's not
determined by a vote science is
determined by as many voices coming
together as possible and then one voice
ultimately
is correct
that's what science is well the problem
is that this this test balloon was
actually floated with climate change if
you remember it was like 95 percent of
the scientists agree and if you didn't
agree that
it was 97 97 that's what they claim
thank you thank you
it's gone up since then right no they
claimed that but if you didn't agree
with that if you you said look we just
need to have a conversation about it and
had some very thoughtful thoughts like
we've had right some thoughtful
conversations like hey wait a minute
maybe there are some benefits to this
maybe there's some drawbacks maybe we're
never going to get china to play ball
and none of this makes any sense like if
you had that conversation you were a
science denier yeah right and so they
set science up as something that you
cannot challenge ever ever ever almost
spilled my water there i do have one
quick note though and you have to make a
decision live on air for this i
apologize i was just passed a note and
if we want him kyle rittenhouse can be
on live in 15 minutes if we want him i
know we're talking about this subject
that'll be about 15 minutes until we're
done with it so it's up to you sir oh
sure i also forgot that we have forehead
on the show tomorrow we just got a text
saying that kyle is available if we want
him i don't know if we can fit it in
today but uh that's up to you yeah maybe
we can fit him in tomorrow maybe you
know what you guys uh
smash the like button if you're how many
months how many do we need put a number
on it 10 000 likes 10 000 likes in the
next
otherwise what i'm thinking is maybe
tomorrow we just do a special like a
guest show with jorge mazvidal yeah and
with cal rittenhouse we'll see which we
don't usually do have a couple of guests
on tomorrow and talk with them
yeah let's do that yeah would it be via
skype that we would have kyle or yeah
that'd be a little easier skype i mean i
don't expect them to waltz on into this
well who knows he could have been around
carrying the scalps of all the
pedophiles years past yeah get a kid
toucher in here maybe he's following him
yeah
shoot me yeah i don't i didn't say it i
didn't only ginger pedophiles are
allowed to use that word um so here's
where we talk about
yes
so we talk about the signs okay the
government science now how does this
compare this is actually something that
not a lot of people know i spoke about
this with with jordan peterson when was
on the show
a common theme with nazi propaganda was
a lot of they didn't just blame the jews
and say hey the jews are bad right no
you needed to find a reason and how it
started was they blamed jews for
spreading diseases things like they
equated typhus right which was spread by
parasitic lice with jews they said that
uh only the jews could get parasitic
lice um the gypsies could get scabies
but it wasn't this big of a deal the
nazis justified putting jews of course
in ghettos saying that it was to what
stop the spread of typhus that was a big
part a big part of how they got this
started was they decided to continue
down this theme of communicable diseases
it was a public it was it was presented
as a public
health slash safety issue the the the
gas chambers that you you know about
many you all know about the gas chambers
yeah
did you know that de-lousing baths were
often used as cover
yes
well you did but a lot of people just to
get rid of lights but
search for meanings is a book i read so
yeah well and when steven says that they
did that it wasn't like one article
right what they did it was every single
time that you went to the theater to
watch a show they had a newsreel that
would play before and they would always
compare
jews to some kind of vermin some kind of
plague amongst us and this was and it
was all under the guise of science right
in public health and just like now where
they say well hold on a lock down that's
not a moral issue
well huh a second i think i think
removing my
freedoms my right my rights my business
i think it's a moral issue they say no
no no it's it's not a question of
ideology it's a matter of health right
that's what we've heard this is a matter
of public health you'll have to put your
rights aside well you know what
strikingly familiar uh april 24 1943
henrik himmler i don't know if you know
him but uh he was a bad chap told the ss
officers
uh
getting rid of lice is not a question of
ideology it is a matter of cleanliness
oh well there you go it's really it's
not a matter of ideology it's a matter
of science he was a dove salesman in
just the same way anti-semitism for us
has not been a question of ideology but
a matter of cleanliness which will now
soon have been dealt with we shall soon
be de-loused
we have only 20 000 lice left and then
that's a lot of straws and then the mata
is finished within the whole of germany
they also use by the way tuberculosis
yeah as a pretext to um exterminate uh
the polish yeah well how did he know
there was 20 000 lies
for all of your 1 000. yeah exactly it
was like jeez
oh my gosh don't get me started on dove
oh look it's interesting that you said
that so 1943 if i had to ask you guys
when do you think hitler was sworn in as
chancellor of germany
i'm gonna go 40. nobody's gonna guess
this right i don't think me too so this
is a slow march
january of 1933
and years prior to this
so when was he a painter yeah exactly
when did he how did he find the time
yeah where now again that'll work
boy he really went from like fine my
paintings suck watch this yeah everybody
thinks hitler just came into office and
immediately went after the jews no he
set this up over time right where people
looked at jews as the others that have
to be so they othered the jews and they
were saying this and by the way this is
how it was
the science says that jews could spread
diseases to the rest of you and so this
is not an ideological issue this is not
a moral issue this is a public health
issue we need to deal with the jews this
other class of people right that's what
they did in germany let's compare that
to now government officials and the
media what are they doing hey hey hold
on a second the threat to the rest of
you
is the unvaccinated
one quarter has not gotten any
in the country as large as ours that's
25 percent minority can cause an awful
lot of damage and they are causing a lot
of damage
the unvaccinated overcrowd our hospitals
overrunning emergency rooms and
intensive care units i'm not going to
say to someone oh look just wait us out
will you just just just wait four or
five weeks and then you'll be able to go
to the pub no if you make the judgment
to not get vaccinated
and you reckon you can wait out
us or the publican or whoever you want
to think you're waiting out you won't
wait out the virus because the virus
will be here for a long time and your
only protection against it is being
vaccinated there is a clear message that
is coming through
this is becoming a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
we are seeing outbreaks of cases in
parts of the country that have low
vaccination coverage because
unvaccinated people are at risk two
different classes of people if you're
vaccinated or if you're unvexited you
have all these rights if you are
basically so that is what it is so yep
yep new zealand unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death for
for themselves their families and the
hospital they'll soon overwhelm it is
obviously difficult for people to shut
up
they want to think about other people
rather than themselves
and blue piss that's the real plague
covered in blue piss yes
that's my coding card
do you like my pearl necklace yes it's
the first one i've actually had since
nine and i leave my hand like this from
my cousin this is how i wave because i'm
this is my thing it's patented it's a
flipper
don't lipper wave don't look in my
garage that's where diana's brakes
remain flipper
go faster um yes now what do we have as
far as examples of that i know you're
going to say oh well honestly they just
vilify the unvaccinated they other them
but you know it's not like that's been
as serious as
you know the ramifications with the jews
of course not yet
and of course delousing didn't seem like
a serious consequence but that's the
march so what do we have governments in
the u.s and abroad like you just saw
those smug pricks in australia and new
zealand penal colonies and a peanut
colony um well with gerald's new
information it being 1930 not new
information but i just found out being
1933 when he was sworn in this has been
a much more swift it's been much more
rapidly absolutely they've banned
unvaccinated uh people from all areas of
public life so how would you consider
this in boston we talked about the man
who was denied a heart transplant
because he was unvaccinated that was
disgusting yeah
and then of course howard stern who by
the way
howard stern uh thinks that joe rogan is
a problem because he has guests on you
know guests who are doctors actual
scientists right more fans than him
right you know stuff like that yeah but
howard stern apparently no problem his
shock jock humor now is making sure to
count out to the man because he knows he
can say this and it sounds mean but he's
not going to get in trouble he won't get
removed
from youtube facebook twitter anywhere
by saying that he wished the
unvaccinated would die me
anyone unvaccinated would not be
admitted to a hospital at this point
they've been given plenty of opportunity
to get the vaccine start government
they think that there's some conspiracy
to turn them into a magnet or something
like this they think they're going to
become magnetized if they take the
vaccine now if you don't get it
in my america
uh all hospitals would be closed to you
you're going to go home and die
hmm hast done yeah oh the same america
that tried to throw you off the air for
25 years right oh those are the people
that you're trusting in now
the real reason people aren't getting
this in injection is because they fear
magnetism there may be like five people
out there i think that actually are like
dude for real right it's gonna happen
well he watched the jordan clapper video
well he must have is that the chip video
right the people think they'll get
chipped yeah this is the market no
you're thinking of the remake chips ah
oh which is not a product oh no he
wasn't in the remake that's why it was
offensive is he vaccined i don't know
but it would be a tragedy for the bottom
of this all of america if eric estrada
is not vaccinated i hope he makes it so
let's get into the science here what
they did in nazi germany so now you've
seen okay we've othered people uh the
science the medical uh community in
germany uh the nazis by the way they
control almost all
mechanisms all wings of the german
medical industry
national socialist party yeah and i need
to make it really clear too because some
a lot the term nazi is thrown around so
flippantly it's lost all meaning when we
say nazis
we mean the government the nazi ran nazi
party ran the government yeah just to be
clear you need to understand that nazism
is not just some people meeting in a
basement with a confederate flag nazis
ran a country and almost took over the
world and this is how they did it nearly
half of all german doctors joined the
nazi party more than any other
profession they were recruited so if you
look at engineers you look at other
categories of employment not even close
they specifically recruited targeted
and doctors joined the nazi party uh and
all the doctors by the way to be clear
they had to complete um
ideological training yeah which is
ironic
because think about it they would say
well it's not ideological it's a health
issue we just read that from him exactly
it's not an ideological issue with the
jews it's a cleanliness issue it's a
health issue we're just doing it for the
betterment of our fellow country right
but then the doctors had to complete
ideological training kind of like here
if you're going to work with the cdc and
you have to uh agree with modern gender
theory right yeah well it's easy to ace
a test when there's a gun to your head
and you know what all the answers are
supposed to be right yes are the jews
bad a yes oh boy oh
yeah uh d all of the above yeah d all of
the above to the other of life do you
want them to we will permit e all of the
above including the d all of the above
that was a trick question we just wanted
to see how passionate you are about you
know the license
you fill out the answers i'll sign it
yes that's right just please let me go
but uh be sure to use your number two
pencil otherwise it
um doctors uh who opted out by the way
this is something you should know kind
of like here in the united states and
we'll get to that in a second they were
dismissed they were forced to leave or
they were sent to concentration camps or
they saved the paperwork and just shot
them yes
seriously this is this is what was
happening and by the way they conducted
some of the worst experiments on humans
in history that we have you know who
else did
the japanese and the chinese yeah if you
look at what they did during those wars
i believe 80 of doctors in austria were
fired
fired when nazis took over the country
so this is kind of what we're talking
about with the police chief in canada
right someone resigns and you don't know
the full story behind that the new
police chief comes in and says we're
going to hunt you down we're going to
punish you for the basically
indefinitely if you've ever taken part
in these protests you look at what
happened in nazi germany it was 80
austria doctors fired and now the
highest number of recruits into the
medical field who have to undergo
ideological training and guess what they
are now
the science the only signs that's how it
starts i don't understand how people who
how rational people whether you are left
or right cannot see
the problem and that it's always played
out this way when you grant authority
and the final say especially it relates
to you know any realm of expertise
exclusively to the government that is
not a good thing you do want some checks
and balances to some can we all agree
that you want some checks and balances
it is remarkable to me when you have
people saying trust the government and
demanding fewer rights by the way we
actually have some archived footage of
hitler's chosen and i warn you
disturbing replacement
[Music]
orders of physicians we'll be replacing
80 of all austrian physicians with
doctors loyal to the right
here's her now
the siamese triplet
connected
via the gastric system
ingestion by aim
only the best here for the third reich
and as the bureau always says
[Music]
ah
so much charm so angry looking all the
time you know you just wonder why god
didn't just spread some of the charm
around just a little bit so uh german by
the way we are going to have cal right
now son oh segment so let's make sure we
get that guys out there on the social
media and i think i think we hit the
like mark so yeah yeah
we need to set a higher bar yeah okay i
mean we want it a million likes
okay hold on hold on
one call written in the household don't
dial that last
number a million likes
uh so let me give you some specific
examples german there was a german
psychiatrist uh john carl uh i have to
say the whole of what john call
friedrich ritmeister his name is my name
too he was arrested tortured executed
for uh even daring to discuss the
atrocities of the third reich members of
the medical student group um the white
rose they were executed for distributing
uh anti-nazi leaflets
let's compare that to now um doctors
here in the united states not to mention
canada australia the only holocaust
that's happening here is with beagles
yes
but they still have lice no that's true
ah can't get rid of that zip eagles it
says 20 thousand lice
hey with faucinas beagles uh it is
interesting when you say that to people
who even love animals and they're like
well sometimes you know you there's
cruel things you have to do really in
science it's like shut up sand flies if
you don't get alive eating a beagle's
face it's like what are you trying to
prevent unless it's you're trying to
prevent sand flies eating a beagle's
face right there's no other experiment
you should be doing i figured you could
do it more humanely than the sand flies
would oh right they're like yeah we can
we cut its vocal cords so we can't hear
it cry right i know that sounds
disturbing to some of you at home look
it up yeah this is the science yes
this is judge science go ahead youtube
pull that because it's science right and
by the way these same people they're the
people who throw a bucket of paint on
someone for wearing a fur coat but then
when it comes to fouchy signing off on
cutting the vocal cords and putting
beagles in
not even cages head cages head cages
yeah just the head i mean they had to go
out of their way to have those probably
custom made to a specifications i want
to just cage the head i want his body to
to feel free to move to to kill him with
hope okay how do you get like a degree
in veterinary science and that's your
first day and you're like this is really
not what i thought yeah i didn't happen
i wanted to become when people always
ask me why i wanted to become a vet i
would answer i want to help animals yeah
there's just
it's a tiger with a beehive on its edge
this seems strange
that's how they tortured people in
vietnam they would put rats or mice in
one of those bags and put your head in
haven't you seen rambo yeah i wanted to
have sick cats not rapa chimpanzees had
an asbestos insulation this is a weird
yeah who is i was in charge garfield
yeah
hey where do i where do i grab the uh is
that where's the food for the uh great
danes is it next to the fiberglass it is
the fiberglass ah wow wow lucy i get
pulling the football but you're a real
[ __ ] yeah and i don't believe she's
ever been to psychology school i don't
believe that that's good advice at all
so let's compare this with the nazis
right parroting this and getting now
today what do we have doctors who don't
uh pair the official narrative we know
this they're completely and the term d
platform is up they are de-platformed
what do i mean by when i say the
establishment meaning they are
de-platformed by people in media yeah
by proxy from the government because the
government says this is dangerous this
is misinformation the cdc labels it
misinformation and then big tech media
say well
look there's nothing we can do the cdc
labels at that yeah that's
the government so anthony fauci let's
start here before we get into media
anthony fauci the science mr beagle
killer himself and francis collins they
colluded with the media to discredit
what was known as the great barrington
declaration i'll explain that in a
little bit for those who you know when
you do a little remedial in an email and
i'm reading an exact quote uh with fauci
collins said this proposal from the
three fringe epidemiologists seems to be
getting a lot of attention there needs
to be a quick and devastating published
takedown
of its premises by the way these uh
fringe epidemiologists just so you know
who wrote the declaration were um they
were doctors from harvard stanford and
oxford oh
so they have medical schools at those
places division three oh yes never heard
of any of the institutes i'm sorry by
the way also um unlike anthony fauci uh
regardless of where they got the degree
they're actual epidemiologists
weird have they practiced in the last 25
years 30 40 years you know give or take
uh your entire career fauci
that's why fouchy and biden get along so
well they haven't held private office
since any of you watching right now have
been born you nailed it no
biden hasn't held pride it's what 49
years that he's been suckling at the
public teat yeah i mean usually people
there each think about anywhere else
anywhere else in the private sector who
by the way get banned because they're
not the science biden would be forcibly
retired fouchy you wouldn't let that guy
run anything at your company like come
on man your time's up but when you're
when you're in the public doll you can
do it forever because it's not about
efficiency it doesn't matter if you have
a track record of being right you're
talking about a guy who said aids could
be airborne and it's not this is what
matters too when we go back to fauci and
the aids thing that he got wrong
just like he got a lot of this wrong and
by a lot i want to couch my words all of
it wrong with kovid um it's not that he
got it wrong it's that there were other
people at that point in time who had it
right yeah when people say well i forgot
you never made a mistake no it's there
were people from harvard from stanford
from oxford there were people back then
who saw fauci as a joke when he said
that aids could be airborne and we
didn't know it was transmitted them
saying we know exactly how it's
transmitted it's when you have to look
back at that point in time and say
did they get it wrong
because there was no information or were
they actively suppressing the
information available right just like in
nazi germany there were some doctors who
said uh no typhus uh is not a jew
problem tuberculosis isn't exclusive to
the polls and then they were disappeared
with the bullet uh bill being sent to
the family it's the same thing here
there were plenty of doctors saying no
no no the imperial college of london the
study is wrong we're not looking at a
one two three four early on some people
said a six percent mortality rate there
were people who had it right
and the only the only reason that we
weren't able to get that information is
because you didn't want to listen to
them we had practicing doctors in
california that had patients that they
were actively treating for this and
saying hey here's what we're seeing we
had these same three schools i think
it's the same three doctors harvard
stanford oxford doctors trying to have
like a town hall meeting with ron
desantis and being banned from being
able to do that and have that broadcast
as well we're not saying that sometimes
they won't have the wrong ideas what
we're saying is
you were so wrong and just a second ago
on cnn they actually put up it's not up
there right now they said a new study
comes out and says that the school
closures have had like a devastating
impact on on kids
you know who's up on there you know
who's up on there right now
serial masturbator jeffrey
and you're
you americans just don't trust your
institutions you mean the guy was
jerking off on a zoom call no i don't
trust him that's not a mundane detail
michael
[Laughter]
no this is you are actively suppressing
all the other voices regardless of if
you're trying or not right when you only
allow one doctor to speak and you're
saying that that's the guy you should
listen to you are doing it deliberately
yes yes bottom line i mean are they the
citizens just as the other the doctors
yeah
this is the science this is it and
sometimes hold on a second you know uh
practicing epidemiologists here from
harvard oh stanford here oxford no can't
can't do that and by the way we got in
trouble for just quoting the cdc's yeah
we got removed
when you have people that are actual
experts and the idea that you have an
expertise in a virus that nobody
understands except for maybe the guy who
helped create it uh but you have a virus
that nobody is aware of or understand
micro penis
3.5 inches not micro you can't be an
expert in it no and that's why
everything is a theory so there's people
that have theories that are going to be
stronger than his just based on his
track record right of every other
disease that he had to deal with you
know like aids where a guy in dallas was
like i'm just going to go over to the
border and start mixing medicine oh look
i'm living longer right yeah exactly
it's pathetic things you have to do to
live well he also bought his medicine
from the magic johnson movie theater
franchise thing
with the concession stands special
sprinkle on their pockets so never have
gone to the stone pony this is one of
again you just look at the march with
germany and it's okay let's get rid of
these doctors let's make sure there's
one authoritative source for the science
let's use that science to other this
group of people in that case the jews he
had the exact same thing here where they
silenced doctors said no no these
doctors are not allowed to be
on these platforms
and then that allows you to other all
the citizens who are unvaccinated and
then you end up with citizens in canada
who can't travel who can't go into
restaurants or businesses and aren't
even allowed to protest the removal of
their rights but it starts with
if you just trust government
for some reason if you mistrust business
but you trust government that's sort of
a tenant of leftism which i've never
fully understood for some reason we
believe that the human condition is
inherently corrupt
especially as you get become more
powerful that power corrupts
that law of humanity just ceases to
exist when you're in government where
there's no financial accountability and
a never-ending pension i i don't
understand maybe someone could explain
it to me you can comment below why
people on the left are so quick to trust
government and so quick to distrust
business i don't the beauty of free
enterprise is i don't have to trust
business
because there can be another business
that tells me if a business is being
dishonest there can be competition you
cannot have that with the government but
it starts with well you know what these
doctors are spreading misinformation on
facebook and uh on on on youtube and so
people say well yeah how do we know it's
misinformation the cdc says so oh okay
we get it dr robert malone not really an
authoritative source just one of the
inventors of mrna technology banned from
twitter
he doesn't know anything about
criticizing the vaccines he invented it
but you know banned from twitter and
having people come out and say that it's
completely ridiculous that he was taken
taken down yeah people that are doctors
along with him and him saying that fauci
is a joke essentially yeah and by the
way we have all references available at
lightweight.com and if you're watching
on youtube though i would prefer you
watch on rumble or mod club especially
because we'll be going excited with cal
written house we do put the references
in the pinned
comment um and here's the thing
the white house itself
even pressured tech companies it doesn't
require a conspiracy theory when they
are doing it out in the open they
pressured the biggest companies in the
world to remove covet and what is
misinformation
any information that goes against the
science of the white house of the reich
they pressured publicly it's not a dog
whistle when you say it on television
in terms of actions alex that
we have taken or we're working to take i
should say from the federal government
we've increased disinformation research
and tracking within the surgeon
general's office we're flagging
problematic posts for facebook that
spread this information we're working
with doctors and medical professionals
to connect to connected medical experts
with popular with popular who are
popular with their audiences with uh
with accurate information and boost
trusted content so we're helping get
trusted content out there so our hope is
that all major tech platforms and all
major news sources for that matter be
responsible and be vigilant to ensure
the american people have access to
accurate information on something as
significant as covid19 that certainly
includes spotify so this disclaimer it's
a positive step but we want every
platform to continue doing more to call
out misinformed miss and disinformation
while also uplifting accurate
information now let me get this straight
dr malone is banned from twitter one of
the creators of the mrna technology
these are french epidemiologists from
harvard stanford oxford these doctors
who were in california who were treating
patients were banned for misinformation
and she is now calling on members of the
media trusted members of the media to
eliminate misinformation keep in mind
that trusted members of the media
include the man we just showed you
jeffrey toobin who didn't accidentally
leak dick pics anyone unvaccinated
wouldn't sorry it wasn't like someone
hacked the cloud
he couldn't wait until the zoom call was
done
he's like i thought i muted that guy has
a seat at the table
dr malone doesn't yeah donald trump off
twitter yeah
uh i'm still there i had to comment
you know he's a little excited he's like
i'm gonna stand up yeah you know exactly
what i was like do i look sexy no you
don't oh tell me how unsexy use a sticky
note like the rest of us well do me a
favor define misinformation and she
added disinformation yes help me
understand what you're talking about
here because you're using terms that are
not definable because you keep changing
what that is
so that you can cover both terms yeah
but so you can cover everything that's
why you fight against terms like hate
speech right because it doesn't exist
misinformation disinformation i get it
define it now doctors here's the thing
if you want to say it's not an
ideological issue it's not a moral issue
i believe that uh i believe any time you
violate people's human rights and by the
way i don't just mean civil rights i
mean human rights there's a big
difference let me human rights are based
on natural rights that means birth
rights right these means this means
unalienable rights meaning
god granted these rights and the only
purpose of government the only purpose
that they serve is to recognize these
rights and to ensure that they are not
infringed upon not that they grant these
rights or take them away the right to
travel freely the right to liberty
pursue the right to run your own
business provided you're not breaking
the law meaning laws that would prevent
you from harming other people these are
birthright the right to see your family
these are human rights they're not even
just civil rights this is worse than not
allowing a group of people to vote and i
know we don't see it that way because
it's not based on skin color though
there's an extreme vaccine hesitancy in
the uh the people of color community
black american community let's just say
i don't know i was about to say colored
community because we had that naacp
thing
uh on yesterday so it's still in my head
but i can't say it no no no we can't but
the point is we don't see it that way
because well it's not a skin color thing
you are actually removing
human rights let's just say this
let's say that you removed
the ability for a group of people okay
what you sp you specified a group of
people
and you said you can't travel
you said you can't run your business
we're going to shut it down you can't go
visit your families you can't go to
public schools
you can't go to restaurants
and instead of on that you just made
them black
you just made them jews
and i know you're going to say well one
thing's immutable and you can choose to
get a vaccine but the government has no
right to force you to get a vaccine and
the reason that they feel entitled to is
because they've eliminated any voices of
dissent and so most people don't know
most people don't know that they've been
wrong on let me tell you what they've
been wrong on okay things like masks
vaccines social distancing the lab leak
theory kind of a big one there
hospitals being overrun china has a bit
of an iou well yeah to the might want to
hang on to that one lab league i don't
know it's almost march and us all dying
on christmas yeah i'm still here joe
that was a fun here's another one if
we're going to say it's not a moral
issue
i can't think of uh anything in my
lifetime
that has been more
of an immoral act committed against its
own citizenry in this country than the
lockdowns and certainly not when you
look at the lockdowns in other countries
that are absolutely draconian and i know
that people use that term in this case
it's entirely appropriate here's the
thing not only is it immoral
and it could only be implemented
immorally because people who spoke out
at that time saying this is immoral or
even saying that it won't work
scientists
were eliminated from the equation
jeffrey tuban still on cnn now we know
definitively johns hopkins fringe uh did
a meta-analysis
that it doesn't work this is a quote
from johns hopkins uh it's i mean you
know johns hopkins they're no fouchy
says while this meta-analysis concludes
that lockdowns have had little to no
public health effects they've imposed
enormous economic and social costs where
they have been adopted and even the
world health organization has now said
that forced isolation and quarantine are
ineffective and impractical we knew this
we knew this at the very beginning we've
known this for years decades decades
decades we've known this this is not new
information and that's why we were
pissed off and it all starts with
determining that the only experts are
the ones who work for the government
that is a problem
always whether it's the only experts to
be trusted are the ex are the economists
in the government
are the uh i mean are the public school
uh uh officials well particularly in the
federal government uh the only experts
in science work for the government the
only take your pick
take have you seen the food pyramid
lately
[Laughter]
you trust that we taught that to
everyone in school
and we told kids that they would be
worse off eating salmon and eggs
than cereal all day
well depends on the serial stephen
now take that add critical race theory
and cove it
trust the experts trust the science what
you really mean is be a lack you be a
patsy for the government all right since
enough of you guys liked and i want to
see you smash that like button again we
have him on the air
right now i believe is he there can you
bring him up so i can see him there uh
tim the tool man mr kyle rittenhouse are
you there sir
i'm here steven how are you doing i am
doing well are you at an airport right
now
i i am in an airport wow okay well uh
skies is an asian traveler yes
you uh you uh you look like you're uh i
mean you look like a narc
can you can you hear me uh well enough
at the airport
yeah i have my uh airpods and i can hear
you steven okay spread no expense so he
has airpods in but he's flying spirit
lovely
uh
no way
no no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna dox
whichever airline you're flying with now
look kyle you actually have some big
news i know that you were on fox news
saying hey there are people who are on
notice right as far as uh
slander libel uh and we did an ash
wednesday with you what's the word now
have there been developments are you
suing people who you know wrongfully
called you a murderer
we are uh working with uh our team is
working on sending out letters to people
such would be
oh
i assume that les that that last
syllable was going to be berg well
goldstein yeah well he's at an airport
there's a good chance someone's just
beating their child so loudly we lost
connection well especially
two people could be fighting over masks
outside of auntie anne's pretzels
you never know all right okay you're
back all right you said whoopee gold i
assumed the next uh was going to be uh
berg schlager
chank from the young church
wait so you're sending out letters to
them what are these letters saying that
you're suing them because you can't send
out a cease and desist because you know
i mean
that doesn't doesn't work you're just
going to sue them
what was that stephen sorry i said what
letters are you sending to them like
it's not like a u.n hans bricks like
you're sending what are these letters
we're sending them a letter that they
have to retract and apologize or they're
going to be paying up and we're going to
hold these people accountable for what
they did to me so nobody had experience
and that's why we started the media
accountability project teammap.org where
people can come and join our fight and
donate and help us fight these lawsuits
to hold these people accountable well i
was going to say you're going to need
those donations because um shank wieger
and whoopi goldberg don't have money
what about joy what about joy behar yeah
what about joy behar could you could
like could you sue the the viewpoint
absolutely good
the view is on the list
for everything they said about me they
called me a white supremacist a murderer
after being acquitted
it's it's just
disgusting how they can do this to
anybody and there's going to be
accountability for what they did
now what would uh like what would be uh
sufficient as far as you know apology
retract like what would you want to see
for you to not you know um take all of
their belongings
for this to not happen to any american
in this entire ever again i don't want
to see anybody have to go through what
went through and be defamed the way i
did
being de-platformed for the lies that
they said i don't want to see anybody
have to go through that no but i'm
saying but what would they have to do
like as far as you say retract it and
apologize like what would that look like
would they have to march out on air
would you write their apology or if they
just say like all right i'm sorry is
that enough and one thing they said they
should donate to the fund right i mean
they really should yes yes at the least
yeah they should donate to the fund like
because you could have fun with it like
you could make them erect a statue in
your honor
i don't know if joy beggar is going to
erect anything
what was that kyle
there's also part two of the media
accountability project okay which is
keeping the media held accountable
by creating a hub for independent
journalists such as elijah shaffer drew
hernandez
nathan de bruin
providing
like
helping them with like training
equipment gas masks
scholarships so they can continue to
grow in independent journalism and also
for independent journalists to post
content
like on a cell phone like you'll have on
your screen
half will be what's really happening
their videos the independent journals
and then the other half will be
what cnn or msnbc is saying or abc is
saying and people can be like wait
that's not what's happening i'm looking
at them right now and they're lying
right yeah well that's so that's the
journalism accountability project i
remember walter cronkite was never
without his gas mask never true always a
key component to journalism uh
it's just that you listed among
everything it's like cameras lights gas
masks but we know exactly why we know
exactly why they're required totally
normal so anyone has to wear one within
five feet of whoopi goldberg yes yes
absolutely well that's just that's
that's genetic child you wait until
you're 75. where's my candy cane thing
um
so okay whoopi goldberg
the young turks um
is there anyone else i mean on your list
you know i mean you mustn't be afraid to
dream bigger love because you know it's
like tiffany cross
tiffany cross uh and these news
organizations that publish this they'll
also be held accountable but tiffany
cross called me a little white
supremacist murder after i was acquitted
these people get away with it but no
accountability is going to be coming we
are going to hold them accountable in a
courtroom okay but you're starting with
whoopi goldberg which i like when are
these letters going to be sent out and
how long do they have to respond and
apologize before you actually sue
they're going to be sent out real soon
we're working on them right now and i'm
not sure how long they're going to have
to reply
but
they're going to be held accountable
yeah what um
what would you like to see whoopi
goldbergs i'll leave you with this
because i know you got to go to a call
but like in your perfect world your
fantasy how would you like whoopi
goldberg to word it
it's a great question um add the word
child at the end i think
i think she needs to go back and watch
the entire trial in a day and then and
fix everything she said wrong and then
maybe i'll forgive her maybe
probably not but amazing oh come on
that's the christian thing to do is
forgive her you can forgive
look you you love the sinner and uh you
know you hate the obfuscation and lies
i believe it says they should apologize
even they should apologize and commit to
not not let this ever happen again
that's what they have to do yeah well
you weren't the first one obviously i
was like nick sandman but you add uh
falsely accusing someone of murder and
it's a little more severe and you know
how big of a deal it was for us we were
just there was a weight lifted off the
shoulders all of us here watching how
about saying something yeah it was
pissed kyle because i couldn't be here
everybody told me that you weren't
coming in and like no no no don't come
into work today kyle's coming in i was a
little pissed off about that but we were
we were ecstatic that the the verdict
came back the way that it did but then
steven said something you should never
for the rest of your life you should
only have to do what you want to do now
like you've been through such a kind of
a difficult time i love what you're
doing with it though you're saying look
it's not just happened to me it's
happened to other people and it's going
to happen again unless somebody stands
up and not just sues these companies but
sues them and then holds them
accountable so i hope i hope that this
project works well so that's that's a
good use of that so thanks
somebody's got to do it yeah well what i
would like to see
yes it needs to change but i'm just
going to tell you this as you're not a
lawyer have some fun with it you know
like again like you could just ask
whoopi goldberg for for simple things
like come out that she apologize that
she you know like get on a weight loss
plan erect a statue in your honor that
you'll be allowed to play the xylophone
on her replacement hip uh you know just
things just there's no reason not to
you're holding the cards kid where's the
organization where's the place where
people can donate to son of a [ __ ] we
lost him no it's not skype don't go to
skype so you brought that up as an ad
i don't want you to have your
information right
the uh
because every time i go to zoom it's
just tube and masturbating t-map
the media accountability project oh i
thought you were giving me the
nickname oh no he stands up his dick's
out we're like well oh well
jeez what airport is he that must be a
layover
it shows how how things have really
changed at the centurion lounge yeah do
people don't care anymore about anything
you got kyle right in house talking it's
eight feet away from you and you're like
hold on time out can you look at the cnn
thing the lower third ukraine's been
giving a new warning by the us of an
imminent russian attack really i think
it happened a day and a half ago yeah
hey guys they're coming
no they're already here
yeah they're like revere riding into
battle like i'm sorry excuse me pushing
away english troops
the british are coming the british are
coming one guy with this like cannonball
legs on his his head and a rapper yeah
we know as hell yeah we know they shot
the drummer boy yesterday yes which by
the way terrible combat move oh my gosh
sends in a drummer boy and a flute well
it's you got to keep morale up i think i
don't think that's what they were doing
bagpipes wanted to know where the other
soldiers were oh well the bagpipes was
definitely in the most danger yeah i
mean you know sometimes annoying because
back then they couldn't have a radio so
some guy comes out in the flute in the
drum you're like oh okay maybe i can go
with this but when the scottish just
when they showed up and there's a
bagpipe like shoot him right away you
actually know that every single soldier
bagpipers was killed by friendly fire
that you know what
i did know that and i forgot it because
it seemed selfish
well i mean the scots weren't fighting
when guns were invented but hey let's
let's keep with the truth yeah then they
all starved it the remaining starved to
death because um their rations were
haggis that's true
[Laughter]
nobody wants no that's like oh
you know there are kids in africa who
don't have to eat that i'd rather have
my mutton than a beaten yeah i'd rather
actually eat your mutton chops your
sideburns i could probably put a little
gravy on it wouldn't have to eat the hat
do you know what's in haggis are they
even knocked out either sounds so bad
even starving kids in china look at it
and say i'd rather eat street food
cooking the series
we're good at drinking
that's pretty
good
stab me first yeah yeah aim for the
bagpipe
here is my music sack
my octopus pipe thing i made i know it's
confusing with the pled like a magic eye
poster so i put a target on it aim for
the bagpipe put me out of my misery i
don't want to have to eat the haggis
it's nine flutes and a sack
i don't know why it's a monster
i try and convince everyone that like i
have control over it like i'm playing
melody but really
when the sound comes out i'm as
surprised as you
i have no idea and for some reason when
everybody dies it's the song you'll hear
it is the cycle here amazing grace on
the bagpipes yeah have you well amazing
grace in the bagpipes
is like everything in the bagpipes have
you ever heard top 40 of bagpipes
sounds the same we're bringing you
number five amazing grace yes number
three my popular request amazing grace
here on casey kasem's bagpipe songs top
40 countdown we have number four hey
baby in it
that's right
it makes the same sound when you drop it
as when you play it yes number two it's
raining haggis it's raining haggis holly
s a t u r d a why no i do i do i do a
great billy joel i don't care what you
say cause it's my
life
just leave me alone
the next song is written by elton john
but i'm not singing it because of his
lifestyle that's right
he didn't have he had the bag he had the
pipe but it didn't make the noise it
wasn't the one
full of lice yes the one you should
never play unless you want to look the
devil right in his eyes yes
you ever looked the devil right in his
eyes and asked him to sing tiny dancer
he doesn't
even the devil doesn't like that little
fruitcake all right
[Laughter]
thank you cal right now tomorrow we'll
have jorge masvidal on the show we're
going to play newest gender pronouns
this is a little bit of a hodgepodge
today i want you to smash that like
button if you're on youtube because
they're not going to be thrilled with
this i honestly i'm always nervous when
we talk about the covid stuff and this
the science yeah you don't want to bring
facts into it no we don't want to bring
a lot of trouble yeah of course i just i
still am aiming to get removed from tick
tock though
xi
you and your tiny festering pustule of a
micro penis
uh we'll see you tomorrow right now
youtube piss off